[Music]
a wind turbine with a difference this EU
funded project is set to be a game
changer when it comes to providing
cheaper renewable energy we are
designing
floating wind platforms to harness the
power of deep Waters traditional fixed
officer wind is limited to water depths
up to 60 meters however the best
resource is in deeper waters and
therefore we have to develop
cost-effective floating Wind Solutions
in the EU the energy sector accounts for
three quarters of greenhouse gas
emissions it is with Innovative projects
like this that the European Parliament
wants to cut those emissions and move
the EU towards its Net Zero goal
MEPS updating the 2018 renewable energy
directive which will help get us there
faster
under the new rules nearly half of the
eu's energy mix would have to come from
Renewables by 2030. we have new
instruments and we have a 45 Target for
renewable energy which is much higher
than the commission's proposal
technology is moving fast with wave
tidal and other groundbreaking projects
rapidly coming on stream
Parliament wants countries across the EU
to promote Innovation and ensure energy
transition projects benefit from Fast
Track planning procedures
sufficient financial support for the
sector alongside efficient regulation
will ensure that the Renewables Market
is not only competitive but fair
clean hydrogen and other renewable fuels
like biofuels and e-fuels should also be
part of the mix
[Music]